Hey Youtubers! It's Charlie.
This is gonna be my Game of Thrones Q&A of the week,
just careful for spoilers for everything that has happened on season 6 so far.
So I'm also gonna talk a little bit about season 7,
they confirmed that there's gonna be a later start date.
I know is kind of a bummer, now our watch has begun.
They basically said that because winter has come, they can't shoot
the show during the summer like they normally would,
they'd be shooting it really soon
But because summertime in Northern Ireland is the most conducive for doing winter type scenes,
they just have to wait a little bit longer in the year to start filming;
meaning that episodes are gonna come a little bit later,
in addition to being a slightly shorter season.
So under normal circumstances, the show would premiere at the beginning of April,
this season was delayed by a couple of weeks,
so I think that It'll be a couple weeks after that
like it will premiere some time in May,
Usually they wait until late in the year to announce, like a ballpark figure
like "Oh we expect it to start sometime in May" or "it might not start until June",
I don't think is gonna be that late,
but just don't expect them to give you a hard date any time soon.
But on the questions, lot of Littlefinger, Tyrion being the third head of the dragon,
and Jon and Dany stuff so, here we go:
First question:
Edgefurre asks "How will Cersie die in your opinon?"
So what I think the message with Cersei is,
is that she will become the tyrant that everyone fears,
and everyone will rise up to crush her,
but I do-- and I really wanna see Jamie kill her.
But the other side of that braavosi coin would be Arya crossing her off her list.
The poetic compromise would be if Arya poisoned her wine,
becasue wine is such a big deal for Cersei,
and then... as she's slowly chocking, Jamie runs her through Mad King style.
But either way the minute she blew up the Great Sept,
and Tommen killed himself, that was it for her.
she's absolutely marked for death.
But because Lena Headey is so fantastic, and Cersei is such a great character
I think they're gonna keep her around as long as possible,
they'll definetly kill her off in some amazing way
but just set out spite: she will outlived most of the other  characters of the show
that they plan on killing off.
Next question:
VirtualSuperSoldier asks:
"Jon and Daenerys' child will be the one who was promised" and then.. nice little joke-.
There are actually a couple of people who suggested this.
There's a lot of people, based on the books, who think that Daenerys might be barren,
she does have a miscarriege towards the end of book 5
So she can at least get pregnant,
we don't know if she can actually carry a child to term.
The reality of the situation is... that I think that Jon and Daenerys will have to form an allience
maybe that's bound by marriage
but I'm not expecting any children from them,
that feels like it would move into fanfiction territory.
George RR Martin teased the Lord of the Rings type ending,
very bittersweet
Now when most people think of that, they think of Aragorn's wedding,
so yay!, very happy occacion!
but I'm thinking more about the end of that,
like when people just wade off in the distance
and then people like Samwise,
or Samwell on Game of Thrones, are left to try and build happiness
in what's left after this big conflict that's over.
So... if anyone is left alive,
like, if anyone is left in the rubble, really sad because their friends have died
It's gonna be Samwell, Gilly, and Little Samwell.
Next question;
Notrece asks:
I think that Jon and Dany are both promised,
but what about Tyrion as the third person?
Could he also be a Targaryen?
Well, just to answer that
I think if there's gonna be a third person to ride dragons,
like a metaphorical third head of the dragon
I do think it'll be Tyrion.
I don't know necessarily if they'll go with Tyrion as a Targaryen on the show though.
The show has only teased that the dragons trust Tyrion
that whole speech of his, I mean,
it was really touching how when he was a little kid,
he was getting ready for is birthday he said that all he wanted was a baby dragon,
it didn't even have to be a big one
and look here you are.
So I think they are setting up some more season seven Tyrion dragon moments.
But just to explain, when people talked about Tyrion maybe being a secret Targaryen,
I guess you're not really a character of Game Of Thrones
until you might be a secret Targaryen,
there's just like an inside joke
but people think that the Mad King had a thing for Tyrion's mother
and has his way with her,
Tyrion was the product of that union
and that's one of the reasons why Tywin hated him so much.
Mostly I think is because of his deformity
and because Tywin really loved his wife, and she died in childbirth,
so he kind of blames Tyrion for that
and on top of that he looks like an imp.
Next question,
Suhrit asks:
How awesome would it be if the song Rhaegar sang at Harrenhal was for Lyanna Stark
and it's the Song of Ice and Fire.
Yeah, It definitely be interested to see if the show actually does Rhaegar and he sings a song,
I think we'll definitely see Rhaegar eventually.
In the House of the Undying, when Daenerys has a vision,
she sees Rhaegar and he talks about this new baby that he's cradling
saying that his song is the song of ice and fire,
but because Barristan Selmy on the TV show teased Rhaegar singing so much,
I think is a definite possibility, we could see him singing on the show.
They have done a good job of paying off moments they teased like that,
like little bits of information.
So they've teased Tourney at Harrenhal,
they've teased  Rhaegar singing,
so presumably they will show that to us eventually.
Next question, Beto asks:
Even if R+L=J,
isn't he still a bastard as his father was married to another woman?
Wouldn't Daenerys have more right to the throne than him due to this?
Well, Jon's status as a bastard really only depends on
Rhaegar being legitimately married to Lyanna Stark.
So there's a couple of hoops they have to jump through,
but I don't think the show is gonna fully explain,
I don't think is gonna matter.
Like... the people in the North have already crowned him King.
Lyanna Mormont said "I don't care who he is, he's our king" and I think the show is gonna stick with that.
If Jon is still a bastard then technically yes, Daenerys would have a stronger claim to the throne.
Next question, Travis asks:
Any thoghts on Ashara Dayne?
Reading the books made me think that she played a significant role.
At first I thought she might be Jon's mother after she got busy with Ned or Brandon.
Well, Ashara Dayne so far on the show...
she is the person Ned Stark took Dawn to
at Starfall after Arthur Dayne died at the Tower of Joy.
He took his ancestral blade home, with the baby enfold
The reason why people assume that Ashara Dayne is Jon Snow's mother
was because of the proximity in time to when Jon Snow was born
like how old the was, and when Ned was at Starfall.
In the grander scheme of things,
Barristan Selmy actually had a big thing for her when they were young
at the Tourney at Harrenhal had he be Rhaegar the loser in that final match
He'd had honour Ashara Dayne in the same way
Rhaegar ended up honoring Lyanna Stark, causing that big scandal.
Next question, Nicholas asks:
What do you think about the theory of the dragons being under Winterfell?
There are a lot of people that wonder if there might be a  clutch of dragon eggs under Winterfell.
Is totally possible,
but I think at this point in the narrative, Jon Snow is the dragon at Winterfell,
like the lore has become the metaphore.
Is kind of the same thing with Azor Ahai,
like people belived that there was an actual mithycal figure
when really is more of a metaphore
just someone who is a mithycal leader who leads them to victory
which is why I think there are multiple Azor Ahai type people.
even if no one actually calls them that.
The only people that had actually used that term are the red priests,
everyone else, if you look ar the wildlings they don't think of Jon Snow as a king
they just think of him like someone to lead them through the long night
just like Daenerys' followers think of her.
So if there were actually dragons under Winterfell at one time,
like a long long time ago
there probably aren't anymore
and now the only dragon at Winterfell is Jon Snow.
Next question, Monica asks:
I don't really understand the Targaryen-fireproof thing
Daenerys is the only one in the show that's been proven to be immune to fire,
Viserys died because of the melted gold Khal Drogo threw on him,
he was pure Targaryen just like his sister.
Jon Snow seems to make a scream getting burnt
when he threw the fire at the wight saving Lord Commander.
I'm so confused
Ok, what the show is doing it's just make it seem like Daenerys has a superpower,
that she has dragons and she's immune to fire
But the show has turned it into a thing that's way bigger
than what it is in the books.
Like Jon Snow seems like he's almost immortal,
he's actually a warg in real life too
but the show hasn't really done that yet.
Daenerys seems like she's fireproof.
Each of them has one big thing that they can call a superpower.
But in reality the way George RR Martin explained
It's that Targaryens are fireproof when blood magic is in play
otherwise they just have a mayor resistance to heat.
Next question, am723:
How is Arya able to use another face when she left Braavos?
So, there's a couple of theories about this,
none of them make any sense.
It really just makes you mad if you try to over analyse this.
The show just wanted to have this big twist,
so it really just threw logic out the window.
Part of the problem with Arya face swapping that girl at The Twins
is that it wouldn't make you taller
she's way taller than Maisie Williams in real life, that actress
and she has way bigger boobs
Switching faces doesn't make your body shape change
so she wouldn't get any taller, and she wouldn't grow any boobs.
But the TV show because it wanted to have that twist
just kind of threw that out the window,
it's like "please don't pay attention to the logic here".
So if you wanna come up with a funny explaination for how she changed faces,
you could say that she pocketed a couple of faces with her when she left Braavos
But in reality the tv show just isn't bothering to explain that.
Next question, Chris asks:
A whole bunch of Little Finger questions, so I like the idea of the Little finger video
but I'm gonna talk a little bit about what I think is gonna be happening with him next season.
So Little Finger is all about twisting Sansa against Jon Snow
and as stupid as that seems, like Sansa should trust Jon Snow
is not like he's trying to do anything,
Littlefinger is gonna do everything he can to make her believe that she has to turn on him
Littlefinger tends to work better behind the scenes, in the shadows
so I think they're mostly going to use his storyline to create drama, like filler drama
until they are ready to battle the White Walkers
because that's like the big external threat
but you need to have internal threats
and everybody seems to love Jon Snow:
the wildings love him, all the northerners love him.
Littlefinger is the only person who hates the sh*t out of Jon Snow.
So he's probably going to do everything he can to poison Sansa against Jon.
Next question, Julienne asks:
Do you think Howland Reed will appear in any of the two seasons to reveal Jon Snow's true parentage?
Actually no, I think the show will find another way to do it.
So... One: I don't think that anybody is gonna question his legitimacy to lead,
so it won't be that big of an issue.
But I think that Bran will probably be the one to tell him.
Regardless of what Bran tells him, or doesn't tell him
on top of all that, I think that eventually Jon Snow will come face to face with a dragon.
and it will cozy up to him a little bit.
and that will be like the show's way of letting Daenerys know that he's a good person,
because if the dragons like him, how bad can he be?
But I don't think there's ever gonna be a situation where he'll have to prove that he's a Targaryen.
If he does have to prove it to Daenerys, I think the dragons will prove that for her.
Thank you everyone for submitting questions, this are always a ton of fun to do.
Comic-Con is coming up in a couple of weeks. So, I'll do a Comic-Con specific video
explaining what all those videos are gonna look like.
They only announced the actors they are bringing
they haven't really said what they are going to show off, they probably do a blooper reel,
maybe they will tease stuff about next season.
I think they will at least tease it, even if they are not gonna have footage
Because of course they are not gonna shoot for a while
so they won't have any footage.
Once we learn a little bit more about their plans,
I'll do a preview video just explaining how my videos are gonna work whenever that stuff comes.
Congratulations to this week's giveaway winner **** you won a $20 Amazon gift card, just be sure to private message me
So because I realised that I haven't done an episode ranking for season 6,
rank all my season 6 episodes from top to bottom.
That's probably what my next bonus video will be, so I'll post that on Sunday.
Be sure to subscribe to get that, but also they'll be a new round of the giveaway when I post that too
While you guys wait for my next video to post, you can click here for my Azor Ahai video,
where I just talk about how the profecy is gonna be twisted.
it's gonna turn more into a metaphore than a literal thing.
And you can click here for my Spiderman: Homecoming, Thor: Ragnarok behind the scenes videos.
Thank you so much for watching everybody, let's high-five. I'll see you guys tonight.